hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to 60 seconds this time
we're gonna win I know what I need to do
okay so I actually have not been using
my scouting time properly I need the one
scout the area there's the radio right
there that oh this is perfect this is
exactly what I need right off the bat
because I need I'm salivating at the
thought of this success that I'm about
to have give it I know I know I know
that that that and no room for that [ __ ]
get this did it go go go okay so what
I've been doing wrong is I've been
getting too much of the stuff that I
don't need this is a different
distribution that I had before why is
this over here why is this over here I
don't know any this isn't the place that
it is so the make any goddamn sense but
it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay
okay getting in again I get my family
members eventually but I need to get the
soup first okay
so the main problem that I've been
having is that I've been getting the
wrong things right off the bat nobody
bit of it okay gotta get the rest of my
family got to get this can of soup
I get that gas mask I don't need the gas
mask because I don't need to send anyone
out before it's time to go out but I'm
gonna get it anyway where's my wife oh
god where's my wife where's my wife
where's my wife where's my goddamn wives
go over your wife wife get that get that
yeah no room with the Frick ah T's okay
so that could have gone infinitely
better that was not good at all we
didn't do anything that we needed to do
oh we started off with the right thing
we may be low on food but with the Boy
Scout manual I've been told this you can
survive five five days in between food
and it looks like we actually had more
food down here that we needed before I
didn't get the map it's one of the
things that I desperately needed was the
map and we found a can of soup down here
and also we found nothing else so so
every five days every five days we can
feed and water our people because now
that we have the Boy Scout manual that
leaves us some more leeway for what we
need to do
we have the deck of cards which means
that we have something to keep us
occupied okay
everyone's fine everyone's gonna be fine
we need to we don't need an expedition
Oh
what's that trickling sound why is the
wall so wet are we about to get flooded
we don't have life preservers save the
supplies yep
save the radio gotta get the radio this
is already off to a bad start I can tell
that things are just about going to be
bad for me in this environment either
this is gonna be the world's shortest
game that was ever played or this oh man
okay everyone's still alive good every
five days it's every five days got it
okay so every five days everyone gets
one of everything that's gonna make our
rations last a long time this is insane
we keep finding spiders everywhere
they're in our soup they're in our water
we swear some of them keep coming back
and they're bigger every time we see
them it can't go on like this we need to
wage war on the spiders this better not
lose me the Boy Scout manual because if
it does I'm going to send every one of
my family members into the radioactive
wastes and have them die from des bois
Onegin the better of turn out good for
me okay
good book is a solution to any problem
they encounter got a bottle on with +1
soup can everything works out for the
best
if there's anyone out there who can
rescue us it's the government since the
government worked out so well for us
last time I say this family is on our
own and if you don't listen to me then
you're probably very sane cuz I'm crazy
listen to me on the dad here I think
anyway hearing strange noises lately is
that coming from outside or is that
something in the shelter with us could
it be we found nothing we feel like
we're going crazy
we should probably get busy with
something to keep us occupied I would
have cards but I'm playing on the game
mode because it's problems if one of us
breaks the radio in our board oh god
everyone has gone insane wow that was
fast
holy [ __ ] I didn't know that was
possible I'm Seth haha we can live with
them noises right we can even be friends
so it's not weird that Timmy is now
wearing a soup can on his head and
pretends it's a helmet this is just
innocent child's play
or is it Mary Jane started acting even
more crazy than she usually does she
need Eames to be making a nest was it
the soup boredom can really get to you
in the shelter it can lead you to dark
places trust us oh man everyone has gone
crazy Oh God
Dolores leave this hellish hole Dolores
go home oh my god everyone gone nuts Oh
everyone's gonna wander into the
wasteland is gonna be the shortest game
I've ever played of this alaura's you
get out there you be good and you bring
back something or else we are all dead
and that is guaranteed go Dolores leave
your insane family alone in this
hellhole - Dolores is out while Dolores
is out everything's gonna be fine in the
hellhole of insanity the bunker of
noises in our head when we open the
bunker door this morning to let in some
fresh radioactive era we discovered a
small suitcase on our doorstep there was
a no note on it and the neighborhood
seemed empty
should we take a look inside of course
what wouldn't we trust that we'd be
crazy not to oh okay
Timmy doesn't look so good inside the
suitcase we found some soup but yuck it
expired a long time ago we're not
feeling very well some of us spend the
whole morning using the bucket in the
corner we're not accepting anonymous
gifts ever again well kids this is going
bad this is going about the worst I've
ever done something we were suspicious
and cautious but after a few minutes
talking turned out it was just a group
of old ladies oh yeah these are the old
ladies that are very bad and that wanted
to rob us but I strike first I protect
my own you stop trying to beat down me
oh my gun exploded what happens if the
rifle malfunctions are we use all our
ammo
huh what is it why did the gun - why's
the gun break Oh God
this is going badly I'm just gonna rush
to the end of this one because we're not
gonna survive here this is obviously not
gonna go well Oh Dolores you're back
you don't look so good you found very
little in fact you only found water okay
whatever we're dad here is dead
Timmy really outdid himself today in a
frenzy he tore out all the pages from
its beloved Scout Handbook and to
transform them into dozens of paper
planes they were flying all over the
place and although we tried to catch
many as we could
it really wasn't many most of them
landed in soups names and in the bucket
unfortunately the pages we managed to
rescue aren't of much use to us the
stable consisting of contents in the
chapter listing 100 ways to properly
take care of a Scouter uniform great
everyone's dead
everyone's gonna die this very night
radio virus silent we need news metal
with it yeah break the radio good idea
leave it to crazy Ted to break the gap
okay well they're dead and Dolores is
just left there with her friggin
skeleton that is great
everyone's dead everyone's dead
everyone's dead everyone said everyone's
dead everyone said everyone's gonna die
die die die die not die the end we all
stole my god Dolores okay obviously that
is not the end of this episode I thought
it was gonna go better than this but
that's not the way that we're going to
have it we're gonna start a new game
this is the recipe and failure that was
the example of how not to succeed in the
game and this next one is going to be
much better it's gonna be good because
I'm gonna find everything that I need
right off the bat this time we're going
to win good like we should have in the
first place yeah let's survive the
apocalypse now it's not quite like
fallout the game but when we have our
family down love each other forever not
go insane again yeah
started the goddamn thing ready Freddie
ready Freddie ready Freddie get you your
might as well your big okay here we go
here we go okay got that Oh Timmy what a
perfect place for you to be I'm just
gonna dump you right in okay that looks
like the Boy Scout Handbook I don't know
where the map is I don't know where that
is
oh god oh god oh god that as cards need
that it it it it it it it it it it it it
it it it where's the freaking there's
map it's on the wall nerd herder herder
okay oh man oh man oh man oh man there's
a lot of soup in one spot here pep trip
yep Hades okay no room that's fine
that's fine that's fine dump those in
there okay get the fire axe that to the
shelter we can get one more one more one
more one more get that briefcase
briefcase proof game get that give it to
get the gifts yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes I hope I didn't forget anyone
did I forget to have my important
important family members no good okay we
got a lot of material in this one we got
a lot of material everything was laid
out pretty much perfectly for us to get
exactly what we need because we have the
map radio flashlight handbook we have
the axe we have a suitcase we have a gun
ammo soup we do not have a lot of water
but we have both the cards check board
and med kit and lock and key is about
the best that we could possibly get we
never thought we'd live to see a dancing
cockroach we still haven't but we saw
one that was nearly as big as a cat the
good news is they probably scared off
any rats in the area the bad news is
they're huge and will probably attack us
when they get the chance okay do not
ruin the Boy Scout Handbook please okay
good it's still there good good good
good good good we dodged a bullet this
time that is if a bullet was huge Harry
had eight legs and the glowing head
hopefully won't have to deal with them
again okay good good good good good
okay day five it's feeding time family
we only got enough water for another one
of these we got to find more water some
hour we're going to be toast
I mean soup has some water in it kinda
weird something about supply drops on
the radio this might just be what we
need to survive it's supposed to happen
near our house god damn it it's the only
thing I don't have the only thing I do
not have is goddamn gas masks frickin
sack of [ __ ] it planned that I in plan
that the commies plan that when they
bombed us they knew I wouldn't have that
yeah it's been a while since we showered
the smell in this tiny shell oh this is
where I shower with bullets for some
reason don't know how don't know how
that works
but I'm gonna rub gunpowder on me and
we're gonna smell real good maybe dirty
or not it's the smell that's the biggest
issue here how do we deal with that yeah
all right okay you know what okay it's
okay it's okay
all right our patience is wearing thin
we thought it would be a good idea to
quickly take a quick look outside to see
if there was any trouble at the area as
we're about to spare a pair of animal
eyes and their owners start growling and
this is where the flashlight comes in
because it's a puppy it's a little puppy
pooper
he's a popper snuper it's a buffer
number listen to the little puppy Snuffy
okay sign to check what's coming for us
with our flashlight and eat a poor puppy
okay
so this is where everyone gets a drink
this is the last one we got so we got to
start preparing for an exhibition oh we
didn't expect to get the phone call so
soon after the atomic bomb drop here
phone ringing outside so much go answer
it Ted you're up buddy get out there
Teddy Boy you gotta show this family
who's the head of the family and you
better not be sick good no need for none
of that but we get still got no water
when we answer the call we could clearly
hear a gasp sound at El Valle okay I
think that's the twins so them calling
us is a good thing because I think
there's probably an ending where we can
do that favorite radio station stop
broadcasting we try to the frequencies
maybe we should treat tinker with the
radio to increase its range
no I'm not gonna tinker with the goddamn
radio freak that ah that's my radio I'm
not gonna do anything about that
we need that radio I forgot that with
the briefcase you can take a whole bunch
of supplies to meet pretty much any
scenario so he's gonna take how long
will he be gone it's a bit of a risk I
mean I don't even know if there's a good
idea to do this but I have a funny
feeling that he's gonna be more
successful in bringing things back if he
has these materials so I'm gonna take a
risk and we're gonna give him to him
he's probably gonna lose one of them and
it better not be the map come lose
everything else not the map don't lose
the map oh crap we're gonna die we don't
have any water
[ __ ] Chet Chet Chet Chet Chet Chet Chet
[ __ ] hey because the flashlight went out
I would have lost it anyway so at least
I grabbed what I needed to grab [ __ ]
we're going to die we don't have any one
tur [ __ ] there's no water here we're
dead
Oh God it's bad we don't have any water
how did this
ha and we are going to die real dead
it's real bad oh [ __ ] we had such a good
start we are going to die Oh No
how did Ted die okay you know what I'm
not sending Ted out anymore and no this
episode is not over in fact a men in
black flash
hello everybody welcome back to uh 60
seconds is the beginning of the episode
and we're going to do good this time
I hope we're gonna survive real good so
here's the rub I want to beat this game
but I'm a little baby I'm a little baby
who's new to the world and I need to
progress and I'm going to progress
because I am going to why is everything
falling over already that's a little bit
disconcerting for the state of
everything that we're going for you but
anyway okay so I lowered the difficulty
because what is why is the radio
screaming at me to get a medkit is that
is that a hint for what we need probably
okay here we go
what what that wasn't the radio what the
hell what the hell why was that done on
the radio why was that not the radio it
was quite obviously the radio what the
hell the bunch of [ __ ] that's what
this is
okay got those that off the wall might
as well lovely wife of mine for some
reason I can't grab the radio oops
oh oh god oh god no oh god it's room
down there they're still alive dan I
threw my whole family down the hole oh
man they're alive
Wow I didn't whoa oh and they're dead
okay never mind
without Ted they couldn't survive
because how could they without their
beloved father leading them to victory
they couldn't win oh man I set the
difficulty lower and I still failed I'm
gonna do this I may be doing it uneasy
but I'm gonna do this we're gonna win
and I'm going to survive and this is
where it all comes down to a father
understanding the limitations of what he
can do and doing what is necessary to
keep his family alive
okay map handbook got it
flashlight tuba good okay
okay okay okay okay okay I think we got
enough I think we got enough I think we
got a lot of materials we did good we're
okay let's see what we got I think we
got everything we needed ha ha that's a
lot of stuff that's a lot of stuff I
like a lot of stuff okay all of us made
it into this shelter just seconds before
the blast I was close as long as we're
all together we can make it work down
here we got a gun bullets in extra water
yes and cards med kit in the suitcase
thank you easy mode hahahahaha
okay so we're low on food but we got
enough food to survive five days 15 15
days which means that we can send people
out with reckless abandon we just got
more food from the lovely people bangin
coconuts outside yes wait we have three
wait what happened to our food we had
more food than that what happened we're
discussing our plans for our first meal
that didn't feature tomato soup when we
heard the yell outside we discovered
that came from a small group of ragged
survivors they were a sorry sight and we
weren't surprised they requested aid we
have plenty of water we can spare water
we can spare you water but nothing else
don't even try to steal anything from us
okay our visitors had problem findings
enough words to express her gratitude
many tears were shed oh how heartwarming
we need to survive alright so we're
gonna send Dolores outside with the
suitcase I really really don't know if
the suitcase is any use
[ __ ] Sheen into the gas mask god dammit
oh wow we are not alone there's a huge
hairy bunny Beast that seems to be
hiding in one of the pipes it's been
poking its head out eyeing our measly
food stash we can't let it get out
we can't let it be in here when we sleep
ah chop its head off gun it down I'm
gonna prefer to gun it shooting a gun in
a confined space is always a good idea
especially at random but yep the gun
blew up our cans were saved too bad for
the hairy mutant guess we're still on
top of the food chain good for us damn
our gun blew up when we tried to shoot
the thing of course it did and I bet the
axe would have blown into pieces would
have caught on fire spur a Stickley just
magically would have blown to pieces and
do Laura's better come back alive or
else I'm going to be very upset Hey oh
oh the Lord and Dolores oh you look good
ha ha ha ha you brought two food back
which is exactly what we needed good
good good good and we got a med kit for
you so you're gonna be a-ok no worries
about a goddamn thing ha ha ha and just
to keep everything in sync we thought
the phone calls Oh Timmy run run Timmy
run run Timmy get it Timmy
ok the lorrison looking better she's
just looking a little bit tired all that
radiation just melt it away I'm just to
keep everything in sync I'm gonna feed
everyone on the 15th tomorrow so
everyone is gonna get fed tomorrow just
so things can stay in sync cuz I don't
have to worry about other people being
fed at one point than other people not
I'm just gonna get everyone fed tomorrow
doink doink doink doink okay who's gonna
go outside
yeah okay you're gonna get the suitcase
cuz I don't trust you with anything else
oh [ __ ]
sleeping problems we used up our med kit
god dammit
oh no someone's gonna go crazy no okay
no one's crazy just everyone's gonna be
tired okay time for eating I don't know
where Mary Jane is she's been out a
while Oh Mary Jane is back and Mary Jane
looks in terrible shape but she found a
lot of food and that's what I like
fork and the food might as well pack for
another expedition Timmy got back to the
shelter from his expedition and looked
fine but it turned out he hurt his hand
with a piece of rusty metal and the
wound was in fact 'add doesn't look like
it's healing up we have to patch it with
an axe I have to cut his hand off no
Timmy no oh oh I guess it's fine
he looks okay Timmy was very brave about
the idea of cleaning up his wound with
the heated axe blade it was a bit
painful but as soon as over the axe is
in no shape to be used again but Timmy
seems much better oh I thought we were
gonna cut something off we should go
outside how about little Tim Tim he did
okay last time why not this time what
could he bring could he bring the
flashlight maybe nothing would be good
for him I can't really risk anything
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna give him
nothing because I don't want him to lose
nothing actually maybe we shouldn't send
anyone out on an expedition we don't
really need anything at the moment and I
want to make sure they get food before
they go out because that might affect
their survival chances I don't know
ah dolor Mary Jane come on emerging
starving caught something nasty god damn
it Mary Jane why do you do that to
yourself
oh [ __ ] everyone looks bad i I guess
mary-jane didn't miss out I'm just gonna
feed everyone today and then cycle back
on the 29th
so now 29th young woman dressed in white
knocked on her door told the story of
her missing twin brothers most likely
held captive she knows that we're good
and trustworthy people and believes that
we can rescue her sibling if we do she
says we might be the beginning of a
solid friendship okay Timmy we're gonna
trust you with this one no good luck oh
you're back okay you're still alive good
let's see the woman quickly called the
group of friends we set out for what
turned out to be a successful mission
finding the lost twin brother wasn't a
problem he was hanging on top of some
antenna next to the fence trying to
escape and his duel with the Bandit
leader he lost a hand but the quick
group quickly tend his injury Sanctus
under times okay that's good Timmy's
going outside
Timmy's take nothing cuz I don't trust
Timmy
group of doctors knocked on our door
today requesting some supplies that
would be helpful we do have extra water
they offer a med kit which would be
unbelievably helpful if they did that
please no they didn't give us anything
in return
wonderful great glad about that that is
cool every new smell attacks our noses
there isn't much we can miss so when a
single brick fell from the wall
revealing a tight opening our senses
were immediately invaded by it should
probably check that hole out and see
what the source of the smell is yeah
that's not to ignore weird smells in the
walls and it was soup that I can spare
not water were fudged we approach all
cautiously what happened next nearly
gave us a heart attack some crazed
rodent pushed our radio I'm uneasy I'm
playing uneasy I'm playin frickin easy
what more do you want from me oh there's
Timmy
where Jane loves cards back from the
wasteland got three bottles of water
good we brought some strange-looking
people back to our doorstep that claim
to be Wizards and we're willing to trade
useful supplies for a few weird trinkets
after hearing them out we decided to
look around our shelter for the items
they wanted they were really ecstatic
about purchasing old pair of socks would
you be lying on the corner for some time
living their own life
the Wizards got them in exchange for a
few bottles of water one of them placed
the socks on your ears and started to
dance they really wanted to sell the
radio yeah I like this [ __ ] it's cool
all right it's good it's good this is
good this is good this is good this is
good this is good so I fed them on the
thirty-third so that means the 38 this
the next time that we send people out
dolorous you're going out with nothing
again because I don't trust the army
broadcast interrupted our breakfast
geographical coordinates sign is still
alive okay this is good we got
coordinates cuz we got a map we got it
well that way our door we got it okay
and a quick glance of the laughs gives
us all the information we need whales
having a message in the bottle it's good
this is good why is Timmy sick god damn
boys everyone gets sick how do they
expect us to be able to keep people
alive their gene wasteland full surprise
like this man on the other side of the
door knocking claiming is willing to
offer a lot for decent ammunition yeah
we trade
sure why not what else do we have to
lose if you can give us a med kit I will
do things I never thought I'd do okay
well that is not as good as I hoped it
would be
and apparently Mary Jane is gone what
happened to Mary Jane did she run away
Mary Jane's sickness got worse and we
weren't able to provide her with the
medicine she decided to cure whatever
she had on her own okay
that's another mouth so we don't have to
feed so long as I make it out alive
because the army is right around the
corner friendly soul on the radio was
talking about a supply Packer you lost
we got to water one soup in one AMRO
yeah
that is good Boy Scout Handbook yeah
wait we can try fixing the gun oh did we
fit the oh we did Timmy we did it you
might be going out of your goddamn mind
but we did it yeah okay and that the
forty-third is one we get to eat and
drink yeah hopefully Delores comes back
my wife I think I love her still not
sure at this point over a month in a
hole that'll do something to you oh no
we don't think Delores is coming back
from the surface it's been too long
[ __ ] well that's not good we almost
forgot about this one time we shared
some water with a group of people who
dress in lab coats out of the blue they
came back today and administered
administered us some very
healthy-looking shots so they were real
doctors after all we think oh they gave
us shots did it cure Timmy yeah Jimmy's
just crazy now he's not hey he's not
he's that sick let's have some
celebratory food I mean it's just you
and me Tim Tim for the rest of life
forever this better pay out because god
damn it I haven't come this far to die I
came this far to survive oh boy Lady
Luck smiled on us we won a vicious game
a war the man wasn't too happy about it
but he delivered on his promise okay
before the world turned into an
unforgiving dead wasteland we were
friends with almost everybody in our
town including the old man Jim who'd
shamble around us treating often and say
hello we wanted to visit him once to
give her some dress took his old man Jim
and such a joker beers that he survived
the blast since he's out of door right
now asking if we want to buy a rock sure
I'll buy a rock hopefully this doesn't
cost me the life of my only son ha ha ha
wouldn't that be something when he open
the door we greeted old man with a smile
he was eager to show us a bag filled
with rich choice of rocks convinces to
take one for free for old times sake we
agreed
can't complain it's good rock glam that
brings us luck we'll see something about
that ok all right Timmy you go out you
may be crazy but I'm not sending myself
if anyone's gonna die it's gonna be you
and not me Oh Timmy you're back you look
slightly tired but at least you're still
is crazy our supplies are scarce
enormous Mel the desperation in the
shelter we're pretty sure there's a
small group of survivors and you're
buying mostly old folks we retire
should be hard to borrow some of their
supplies are old no I'm not gonna steal
we got enough supplies we're fine we
don't need a steal Oh Timmy he was
always a wild one a shelter is not the
best environment for a boy who's
hell-bent on running around and dig
until he can barely breathe he really
misses that he asked if he go to the
surface even for a short while that
sounds highly daring juris and
irresponsible should we agree yeah
get out Timmy get out you freakin terror
stay out Timmy can sneak like a secret
agent man but that night might not be
enough to avoid the band of Raiders camp
near our shelter we can probably assume
he isn't coming back when we consented
Timmy almost hit his head on the ceiling
right cuz he's crazy we figured that if
he doesn't encounter any savages mutated
beasts are killing mimes he should be
fine and back enough soon yeah he's got
the survival instincts of a crazy person
heard a knock at the door this morning
we held our breath in fear but we soon
heard children's voices coming from
outside turned out voice para Girl
Scouts they offer a Boy Scout for a man
I've used the map I've used the map I've
used the map in both contexts that I
needed the map which was for the radio
the government and for the twins I need
that book I need that book and dad is
a-okay to stay in here for as long as he
needs to he's got no family left but he
was never a family man to always gone
crazy the other day we heard a quiet
knock at her door but when he opened me
was only a suitcase knowing around
signal looks a little okay sure it could
kill us but whatever I'm a trusting kind
of guy yep do sick got bad soup good
good good great great great bad soup
we're about to sleep when we heard
scratching from the door first sound
like an angry rat much worse something
is on the other side we need to act lock
the damn door at least the lock is gonna
be useful gosh we didn't think a small
padlock would be enough to stop him but
it turned out to be enough to discourage
the unknown attackers it seemed that
they gave this whole break-in a fair
shop with all the mail he gave up and
left who bad the padlock is in no shape
great time to eat crazy sick person you
afraid the army wouldn't get back to us
but they eventually did the next
transmission with school of excavation
evacuation promises but it ended upon a
big if the speaker requested that any
survival groups armed with firearms
should dispose of them before they get
rescued we don't know what this is about
but it sounds like violating our rights
on the other hand are there any laws
left no I'm not giving up my gun you
screw you that didn't go well for me
last time eat a dick government we
decided to ignore those stupid orders
who are they to tell us what to do the
US government well they probably are but
that doesn't mean they can take our gun
over our dead bodies well
Ted's going down Ted ain't doing good
bandicam nearby not only the armed
dangerous cruel and bloodthirsty fine go
get him
Teddy Boy bang boom bang bang boom bang
bang tried our best but they had numbers
we didn't even manage to reach the
supplies the campus too well-guarded
that huh yeah go get him go get him
Teddy Boy go get him you the man you the
man Ted man these are still alive I
guess
oh we bravely stormed in but no one was
there we took a soup can oh we lost the
soup can Ted Oz always had a heart of
gold that's why we were really shocked
to find him feeding our supplies to some
disgusting fat cockroach well Ted in the
bug seemed really happy so we didn't
manage to stay mad for long although
when Ted starts sharing jokes and life
stories with the cost grows we forget we
became a bit suspicious Oh dead corpse
in Dolores I think your husband's
cheating on you with a cockroach ha ha
ha ha ha another radio broadcast from
the military was a huge shock for us not
only did they postpone a rescue they
also ordered all survivors to get rid of
their firearms are they nuts how are we
supposed to defend ourselves it better
be worth
no I'm not giving up my damn gun
it didn't work for me last time you're
not gonna make me do now so screw you
and your freaking face up there you go I
guess we died from sickness finally god
damn it we survived for 68 days how were
we supposed to survive any longer
I tried I've really tried I need to look
up guides on this because I am trying my
freakin best was I supposed to give up
my gun oh no no didn't work out last
time and said the government quarantined
us what a load of ass so is the end of
60 seconds for now I'll do another
episode where I'm gonna beat it on
normal some of them I'm good I'm good at
this
I'll show you guys who's good this guy
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video we just so happened a
surplus of water so I'm a okay with
trying this bottled water
let's known about flood to shake anymore
on the dance floor if any of you guys
meet me in public